what do you think it is about the street
fighter concept that like I know why you
would want to make a Street Fighter
movie but for you as directors enhancing
your craft from film to film what
opportunities will it give you that no
other movie could I think that's awesome
that we have such a connection with the
game and to the characters and there's
not like a pre-established big film
franchise where we have to like fall in
line of like an overall plot I think
we'd have the freedom to create what
that overall art could be if it was
going to be a bunch of films and also we
just love we'd love the chance of an
action film we'd love the chance to do
big set pieces of a big budget because
like even on our YouTube stuff we're
designing stunt rigs that had never been
done before and to do that on a grand
scale man I feel like we could create
something no one's ever seen before
yeah and I think it's like diving into
the lore of street fight all the
characters where they come from has been
so exciting and it's like you you just
get endless ideas so put it into the
screen yeah I think we can make
something special but I will say I don't
know if that's going to be our second
film
we could squeeze in another one before
that
I like the sound of this I'm going to
ask one more Street Fighter question
because when you're developing a film
for a very popular franchise like that
pressure is Sky High people want it to
be exactly the same as the thing they
already know and love so what is
something about Street Fighter that you
know it is important to uphold in your
film but then I also want to know
something that you think you could bring
to it that will make it Uniquely Yours
and maybe give people something they
didn't even know they needed from a
street fighter film well we definitely
want to pay
um tribute to all the hadoukens and and
all the all the characters Powers I
think that's an amazing thing to be able
to translate and put on screen that's
really exciting and to create some of
those impossible moves uh on camera I
think would be incredible and then
something even the settings like the
levels like that where where the fights
are based like they're so iconic like
doing Justice to them like bringing that
visually to life and just capturing that
fun energy of Street Fighter yeah and
then something I don't know if we change
but I think that
there's a lot of backstory with the
characters but it's cool that we could
have the essence of a character and then
and then give them
like a deeper richer
like but if it's Rich it's Rich when you
look at it there's so many comics and
books in that based on them I hear you I
do hear you good thing this guy's not
writing you know
we'll have to fight that out yeah